[Music]
i'm a 45 year old dude with plenty of
gray hairs
crushing on tick tock because you know
because i'm reading what 15 year olds
like from what i'm saying and i'm also
reading when they say i'm [ __ ] old
and finished and i suck and i'm
adjusting
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
trading secrets today we are talking
with the serial entrepreneur angel
investor chairman of vaynerx ceo of
vaynermedia multiple new york times
bestseller fortune 40 under 40 list
digital media mogul i'll tell you what
if that's not enough gary serves on the
board of mcmake bojangles restaurants
and pencils of promise honestly i could
have done that for about 15 more pages
but i had to pick some of my favorites
so that being said we have what i'm
gonna refer to him as just the electric
factory garyvee here garyvee thank you
so much for being on an episode of
trading secrets with us today i
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me on good stuff well we got you
for a little bit of time here so i want
to dig right into it usually i might
rewire my guests start from the
beginning to see where they are today
but i'm gonna i'm gonna get right into
it and when i read everything you've
done gary and of course you know we
follow you on instagram and your youtube
your podcast everything the one thing
that just blows me away is that you're
always like eight steps ahead you're
like a [ __ ] magician i don't know how
you do it and for anyone that doesn't
know in the intro i'll i'll give some
more information we will in the recap
but you're an early adopter an angel
investor at a company huge company
facebook twitter tumblr venmo snapchat
coinbase and uber we'll get into your
nft stuff here soon you're also one of
the first guys at an e-commerce business
with your wine youtube right after
youtube launches how is it from the 90s
to 2021 and even before that you're so
many steps ahead like what are these
tactics that you do that maybe we could
implement into our lives
i think one is extremely tangible and
one is like something that i continue to
try to spend a lot of time figuring out
because
you know one day i'm going to go into
the ground and i'm not i think the world
is abundant
and i love it's you know actually one of
the things that i think is real is that
my framework around abundance and how
i think everyone can win and like
i i try to share all this stuff right
like the second i decided nfts was the
next thing since social
i got loud it's not like i went and
picked up everything you know like yeah
maybe once in a moment i'll pick up a
little something before i tell everybody
everything but
um
so i think the biggest thing that i do
that everybody here can do
is spend a lot of time listening which
always makes all my friends and like
even like people that are
this is a great crossover show i think
you know there's definitely some people
that hear this for the first time that
hear about me for the first time in this
and you know my intensity my jersey my
you know east coast my alpha my
competitive it's so abundant in the way
that i communicate but all my soft
skills and all my other attributes are
kind of a little like less obvious right
and so
i think the
thing that
everybody can do is spend a lot more
time listening i'll give you an example
sure i read the far majority of my
comments and dms to this day
seriously seriously now here's why
i've had this career of being ahead i
know that what i'm really doing is
research
okay right so when you think of it as
like
harding somebody back or saying what's
up first of all that matters my second
book i ever wrote was called the thank
you economy and like if you want to
build something connections matter and
the internet allows you to build a
bigger connection right you can you can
scale connections i think everyone is so
i think everyone isn't humble enough of
humility let me give you an example
i am at a very
big place in my professional career at
this point i'm like [ __ ] man i'm 45
and i'm like the momentum is really
building right like the last three four
years was like really on fire with a big
base right and so
i'm like man i'm really like you know
sometimes i'm like man these next 10 to
20 years are gonna be weird like i'm
gonna be way the [ __ ] up there you know
and so i uh but yet i still for like two
hours last night read two hours worth of
discord conversations on seven brand new
nft projects that have a .001 percent
chance of being the next board api club
of b friends or something quote unquote
worth the time i put in it comes from
humility even where i'm at and this is
me saying i'm at a high place isn't for
me to stroke my own ego it's for
everybody who's listening who isn't more
professionally successful than me to say
if i'm willing to reply to people and
read their comments and do it like why
are you fancy after you've gotten 10 000
followers and now you're not replying to
the comments or thanking people to who
[ __ ] with you or reading the comments to
get a sense of where should you take
your content or where's the temperature
of the world right i'm a 45 year old
dude with plenty of gray hairs
crushing on tick tock because you know
because i'm reading what 15 year olds
like from what i'm saying and i'm also
reading when they say i'm [ __ ] old
and finished and i suck and i'm
adjusting
got it all right so the reason i'm blown
away by that though is because like so
this morning and i'm like kind of
punching myself we have one account
that's about 110 000 followers all in
career management and we're literally
strategizing who can respond to the dms
because they blow they're going crazy
and it's like it's like a negative right
it's like who's the lowest man or woman
like right it's like seriously yeah
where meanwhile i flipped it i'm like
this is the [ __ ] magic
it's brilliant it's brilliant i've got a
good one if you're listening to the
podcast uh google gary vee space uh pete
uh psp right uh uh i'm i'm sorry i'm
sorry it was creative strap pcs i've got
so many acronyms in my company pc gary
v-e-e david i think i see you doing it
so let me know if this pops up garyvee
space pcs
i wrote a blog post about this new
position i created at vayner vaynermedia
by the way with all the stuff that i'm
doing jason people don't realize i'm the
active ceo of a 1400 person global
marketing company and that's what i
actually do sure sure yeah and in that
company because of me gary vee yeah
doing this work that we've been starting
this podcast with him jason this is a
real like coup for you a little bit i
don't really talk about this that often
so you put me in a good spot so i have a
funny feeling i'm going to send a ton of
people to this podcast to hear this
i created a position in strategy
called a pcs which is the post-creative
strategist her and his job is when we
post for a brand like pepsi or budweiser
all the all the companies we work with
to read all the comments
to then form an opinion or an
observation to then help make the
creative on the next post better
it is actually the answer to your
question i've been reading the room
the culture the society the humans
i'm very good at understanding history i
was a terrible [ __ ] student except for
history so i understand that what people
said about the television and what
people said about i'll give you a good
one do you know why i know nfts are
going to work why is that [ __ ] that
people told me about twitter and it's
the same [ __ ] that people said about
credit cards this is stupid i'm not
going to do it so you're seeing the kind
of the same behaviors whether it was
youtube three months four months after
when you started your show or the early
investment in facebook or twitter or now
crypto and nfts you're seeing those same
patterns circulate and you're
identifying the same thing that was 20
years ago is today and that's what's
driving a lot of your behaviors to be
three steps ahead is that fair i watched
exactly i watched the same movie play
out over and over
i know what it tastes like now in the
beginning with the internet in 95 i was
like [ __ ] man this feels like it's going
to change the world i was going on
spidey this is the part that's not
scalable right i've had i was at a
baseball card show in 1993 when i was 17
years old selling cards and just decided
that i didn't like the way that the show
was flowing i didn't feel what i felt at
shows before and decided the card market
was about to collapse and literally sold
the majority of my collection and
literally six months later the entire
market collapsed it's brilliant because
it's not only the reading but it's also
the executing and that that brings me to
another question because i watch your
larry king interview where you said this
was 2016 for anyone that hasn't seen it
yet and so what you say is that you
believe that our tv was becoming is
becoming the radio and that our phones
are actually becoming the tv so again
back to kind of our theme here of
looking at history and bringing it to
today five years later that statement
right tv is becoming the radio phones
are becoming our tv would you modify
that statement at all
uh no because um you know obviously
streaming is a monster
right and so the way tv is being
consumed is different
the context of that larry king thing had
a lot to do with marketing so right so
i would actually say that point is even
more valid because what i didn't see at
that point though i was very bullish on
netflix and an investor even back then
was
how fast ot i mean
you know how beside the show that you
were on yeah like like literally besides
sports and like three years
and the bachelor honestly like what else
is programmed what else do people
actually watch on let's say network tv
and then cable has been annihilated
you know youtube netflix and social
have completely absorbed the human you
know
attention span and so yeah i mean i
think you know the context of that was
around commercials and why market you
know i was explaining to larry my
company which is the mat what i was
saying was like in his work you know
trying to land for him i was like look
we're a modern madman right we're the
best agency in the world once starbucks
and ford and toyota and nike understand
that making 30 second commercials with
the majority of your money that you
spend on marketing is [ __ ] asinine in
2022.
absolutely and so then i i think you
would assume that like network tv cable
tv and maybe five ten years ago it will
just be non-existent yeah i mean i think
those companies kudos to them whether
it's peacock or other things like
they're they're gonna just like they
went into cable after they realized that
was a problem and brought up networks
they're gonna go into streaming the
problem is
netflix doesn't seem like they're
fooling around yeah they got they got
some moves they're making moves they're
doing the right thing one thing you
talked about garyvee and you already
brought it up was nfts so i want to
quickly talk about it from radio to nfts
in two minutes we're trying to cover it
all here so for anybody that doesn't
know there's 2 billion spent on nfts in
the first quarter if you look at nba top
shop they are just blowing it 600
million plus and then you come in and
you launch uh my understanding it's v
friends and that from your launch like
almost instantaneously after your launch
you guys are making 50 million plus so i
need i need this a two-part question the
first one is a 101. someone that hears
you say nftv friends
let us know the one-on-one and then
we'll go from there there's a lot to
break down here so i'll go fast uh i
just pushed my my 5 30 by five to seven
minutes so it'll flow a little over here
we go
101 nfts first you have to understand
that web 1.0 came and organized
information literally i'm old you know
you i used to not be have google and
yahoo and i had to go to encyclopedia
which is why i got f's because i wasn't
willing to do that um
that was information
web 2.0 2567 which i really crushed with
my you know my investments and i didn't
have a lot of money [ __ ] if i had the
kind of money i had today then i would
already have the new york jets and i'd
still be reading comments by the way i
love the game [ __ ] the money [ __ ] the
accolades i love the game but
um that was documenting communication
what i understood then was oh my god the
way we interact
is not gonna be as much on a telephone
calling writing letters and meeting in
person we're gonna use this it's gonna i
used to call it aol instant messenger
6.0 that's what i used to call it in my
head this myspace friendster thing and
then facebook came and twitter came and
i was like okay it's over
so information 1.0
communication 2.0
consumerization
3.0
we buy [ __ ]
humans buy [ __ ]
and a lot of times the reason we buy it
is to communicate to the world look what
outfit i'm wearing look how expensive my
watch is it is not acceptable to roll up
on somebody and tell them how much money
is in your bank account but it is
actually overly accepted by our culture
to wear a seven the eight thousand
dollar watch or 250 and people know so
we're peacocking the same reason we the
car we drive our facial hair everything
we do is communicating
we do that through words that was 2.0
that was social media but we do it
through stuff
now when you take that macro cuban
historical thesis that i think i
understand well yeah
and you layer what's been going on for
the last decade which is digitalization
for communication
do people value a blue check on
instagram
they do do you believe that you have
friends who if somebody was like
if you give me 20 grand i can get you a
blue check on instagram do you believe
they would pay for it a hundred percent
yes okay so that is a digital that's
right that's a digital asset
that means you don't own it you can't
[ __ ] touch it but for some reason
both of you know and everybody listening
was nodding their head
that there's a ton of human beings that
would buy it why because our life has
become equally digital as it has become
non-digital and status
follow count
blue checks
digital things you can't touch
matter a whole lot your wikipedia page
your google results i don't touch that
[ __ ] sounds like it's really valuable
you layer that with watching the kids
and how much they're willing to pay for
a fortnight skin
my nephew this is real i'm gonna read it
live live this is live my sister texting
my brother and i because she knows this
is my thesis okay she texts this kid
this is her son who's 11. this kid
better learn nfts soon because he's
negotiating money for more skins right
and then she wrote then she wrote what
did she write oh my lord he went from
asking for 11 to 25. my nephew max wants
25 right now to buy a fortnight skin
because he wants to communicate or power
up in fortnite sure that's happening in
video games in madden in 2k in fortnite
it's happening in candy crush i knew
this would the reason there's videos of
me talking about virtual goods in 2010
and everybody thinks i'm a prophet
yes i got it but i didn't get it this
way what it was was farmville people
were already buying [ __ ] sheep on
facebook with real us dollars and i'm
like right so
basically nfts are no different than a
rolex or a pair of off-whites because
you want people to see what you have so
i think now i got a real deep one coming
let me drop you my third one so i
believe nfps are gonna do that for
everything okay the reason fashion works
the reason fortnite works is the reason
nfts are gonna work people will have
public wallets and people will be able
to see what's in them
got it got it this will become the new
social network i'm gonna look you up on
wikipedia or or google i'm gonna look
your right jason david you guys meet
somebody brand new they walk away female
male whatever it is and there's always
different things business hook up
whatever everybody's living you're gonna
look at their gram right you're gonna
look you're gonna look i believe in ten
years everyone's gonna look at
everybody's public wallet because
they'll see what concerts you went to
because your ticket's gonna be an nft
they're gonna see how you flex with your
kid hey do you have money like listen
that's a real talk people think about
that [ __ ] they're gonna say oh [ __ ] he
has a expensive crypto punk that's flex
cause that's like having a [ __ ]
banksy painting in your wall when they
come to the apartment this is all human
[ __ ] it's just going digital
right yep and the big one is on social
we control our pictures right on social
what's happening now is we're pr agents
of ourselves
sure
when you buy something you can't alter
it i actually believe i will have a
better read on people by looking at
their nft wallet in 10 years than
looking at their social media so i was
going to ask you how do you keep
momentum in this space because if you
analyze how many nfts are being bought
on a month-to-month basis it's this
crazy high low volatile dip in and
that's because it's all over because
it's internet 95 you can't this whole
thing is a lot of the projects that are
out right now are going to crash to zero
we're in the we're in the gold rush part
of it right now this is internet stock
95
pets.com is in the mix right now there's
there's been something that has been
spent 100 million dollars on that is
definitely going to zero because the
supply is going to outpace the demand
the problem is what i want v friends to
be what i think crypto punks is is the
amazon and aol stock when everything
went to xero fascinating so in april of
2000 jason history lesson time the stock
market collapsed of all the internet
stocks because it wasn't sustainable
just like these individual nft projects
right now are not sustainable
got it the problem was amazon was a
[ __ ] five who though i gotta go do my
homework probably 5 10 15 bucks a share
that would have been a really good idea
that would have been a brilliant one so
whatever but now i got to tell you what
everybody wrote was the internet's a fad
that was the article see the internet's
a fad it's not a sustainable business
it's not real sure
what was really happening was they were
judging individual executions not the
overall thing there will be nft projects
that go to zero and there might even be
an nft winter tomorrow six months from
now two years from now
but the macro
of the nft movement is beyond real and
this goes back to your exact point we
started this conversation the whole
macro ideology that you hit play the
whole movie press plays and the whole
movie restarts and now this movie is the
nft movie and it sounds exactly similar
to like you said amazon 15 20 bucks a
share people were saying it's a fad
we're hearing the same things with nft's
question for you you want a good one
real quick before you segway go go go
google social media is a fad
right okay
i mean the amount of people that wrote
that was astonishing yeah
you know
i got a quick question too what do you
think is a better long-term investment
place since v friends and nft spaces
usually ran off the ethereum platform do
you think ethereum or bitcoin is a
better long-term investment play
um
i believe
that i'm more bullish on ethereum
but i'm incredibly bullish on the
bitcoin community as well but i've been
pretty consistently more bullish on
ethereum i think bitcoin in a lot of
ways
is more stable because it is the gold
whereas ethereum could get out innovated
by another chain
but i'm incredibly at this point
still
more ethereum but the fact of the matter
is i'm also not educated enough to give
you a tremendous answer on that i'm more
bullish nfts because those can sit on
ethereum or they can sit on polka dot or
they could sit on so they could sit on
something else in the future i don't
care what it sits on it's kind of like
saying gary are you more bullish yahoo
or amazon and i would have said you know
i love amazon
but i bore bullish on search engine
and what ended up happening was it
wasn't yahoo it was [ __ ] google right
i'm i'm not sure if it's a theory i'm
feeling like it might be but
i'm more bullish on the human behavior i
don't have the technical know-how or the
understanding of central financing and
banking nor do i understand what
sovereign nations are going to do with
legalities to impact all this but what i
can definitely tell you that i can't
wait to clip in 12 years when i'm bald
and not as good looking and i'm gonna
have the side-by-side video like i
always do with my other content and and
i say see this is gonna be a c moment
what i know is what i know
is that a stunning amount of people
are gonna buy digital assets the way
they buy handbags sneakers chachkas on
their desk hats
toys uh sweaters it's gonna be way more
digital than people think i love that i
never in my thought and never in my mind
ever thought i would think of the
following comparing different
cryptocurrencies right now to search
engines and being like okay which ones
ask jeeves which one's google it's kind
of a wild thought jason because at the
end of the day what this is all about is
who wins the game of brand
right
right because there's the technology
part
and listen when you outpace everybody on
your tech you win google search engine
was so wicked crazy
they changed the way search was done so
the results were so good that then it
was [ __ ] over right the iphone this
thing came out and everything else was
like a piece of dog [ __ ] you know like
yeah
unreal all right so it's like a full
sprint trying to touch a little piece of
gary's life all within this but we're
gonna try and do it for those that don't
know the cool thing about garyvee also
has this fascinating youtube series
called trash talk and so this was kind
of like the blood and spirit of the the
animal at seven when he had a lemonade
stand making thousands of dollars he'll
go to garage sales find goods find
pokemon cards trading cards etc he'll
buy them and flip them so if you have
any uh comments on trash talk i'd like
to hear them but i really are curious
the best return you've had from doing
something as simple as going to a garage
sale and then
my brother and i went to a garage sale
probably in 2005 6-7
it was like 1 30 p.m when if you're an
og garage seller you know that's it's
finished that's the end of the night you
know like 1 30 p.m is like [ __ ]
midnight it's over
and we were just like
kind of beaten and battered it wasn't a
great great day
and
we just pulled up and it was like
you we judge garage sales like
immediately like oh [ __ ] it's a 60 year
old guy we like pop culture you know
youth toys video games that's what we
knew best this was before iphone is on
you where you can look up [ __ ] so you're
going on [ __ ] memory and your [ __ ]
skills of the night me and aj used to
spend hours on ebay completed auctions
doing research just so when we go to
garage sales be like oh forks like i'm
like [ __ ] like staplers are worth money
they are like you know like that kind of
stuff right and
he finds this box
and he i see him negotiating and it was
one of my proudest moments because he's
only like 14. i was a young kid at that
point he's 11 years younger than me and
he gets the box for like 10 bucks it
started at 20.
and
he started a 5 which was a tactic i
taught him because when he was really
like 11 and 12 if it was 20 you'd be
like well you take 18 and it was over i
was like no they asked 20 you asked five
so you can settle at 10. like you need
room right so i was really proud already
of how he negotiated and then he looks
at me and his face like bro and i'm like
what and he opens the box and it is
loaded with super nintendo rpg rare
games like you would not believe he paid
10 bucks for what was flipped on ebay
for like
7 800
that's brilliant that is brilliant
780 times at a garage sale i mean we
found a gunned sailor bear for 10 cents
that sold for 390.
there's some good [ __ ] but it's crazy to
me so i got it this wasn't it but i'll
tell you jason ready let's go full
circle
started getting comments because i would
talk about like what you can do for 25
000 investing what you can do started
getting a ton of comments yo [ __ ] you
rich dude i got [ __ ] 80 bucks [ __ ]
you gary you [ __ ] lost touch with the
people i got 100 bucks i was like fine i
was like let me show you what i did from
17 to 25 when the [ __ ] i had dick
[ __ ] i was like this is what i did i was
[ __ ] hungry i wanted to save more
money i had time and instead of golfing
or watching [ __ ] college football my
saturdays were garage sailing because i
had knowledge and i [ __ ] had hustle
and humility i didn't give a [ __ ] my
cool friends would make fun of me could
give two [ __ ] i was going to the garage
sales and [ __ ] buying you know
spending 89 and coming back with a
thousand a month later buying all sorts
of pop culture happy days this wizard of
oz that the you know [ __ ] the alf
doll this you know like you know
backstreet boys board game that like
super pop culture super pop culture
and so which is why i'm so prepared 35
years into my business career to build v
friends i'm gonna build pokemon i'm
gonna build power rangers i'm gonna
build care bears and i know how to do it
i'm going to use nfts to do it which i
never thought possible but it was all
this training of pop culture
and so
it was me reading comments that led to
me doing trash talk the show i'm like
i'm going to show people how to go from
80 bucks to 80 000 if you go to trash
talk six which is the current one a guy
rolls up on me super emotional and goes
me and my wife do this because of you
and i could see he's emotional so i like
kind of give him a hug and it shows me
he shows me his phone he's like this is
because of you and i'm like no it's
because of you you put in the work i
talk i give away free game all the time
you did it and i see his [ __ ] ebay
paypal it's got 34 000 in it and i go
how much do you start with and he said a
hundred dollars unbelievable and
literally what's wild about the question
that you just answered it goes back to
my original question like reading what
the future is i didn't even get to get
the question out of my mouth you knew
what i was gonna say before i was gonna
say it because this is a guy who blinks
in a million dollars falls in his lap
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing at
a garage sale for a ten dollar uh card
it goes back to the comments the
research
it's why i understand like it was funny
like towards the end of his life which
is so tragic i you know i started really
being like oh [ __ ] i understand kobe
bryant
i'm like
he just liked the game
yeah
and like to me like even when you said a
million dollars opens mouth whatever i'm
like like you know i'm like i don't like
when i tell you
it would break your face if you cut me
open and read the data you'd be like wow
this guy really wasn't full of [ __ ] he
just doesn't really give a [ __ ] about
the money of course i'll take it of
course it makes your life better like
let's not be delusional i'm not [ __ ]
out of my mind i understand the value of
money in society
but when i tell you
i go find a video game i found a [ __ ]
thunder cat
that's worth 34 bucks on ebay and i
bought it for a quarter this was like
episode two i can tell you because i'm
telling you the [ __ ] truth the
chemicals that went through my body was
more exciting to me we just landed a six
million dollar client for vaynermedia
the other day
i was happy
but it was
you know and so like that's like public
speaking like it's not really a great
use of my time anymore this podcast not
a great use of my time sure you know
it's a great use of my time
i know that this me being on your show
will help you get bigger guests
because i know what i what i mean right
now to a lot of other bigger guests
i know that i'm gonna link this at some
point and a lot of new people are gonna
discover you that's karma that's doing
right by somebody i also know
that you may ask a question in a way
differently that makes me say something
that i want to clip and put on my thing
that's going to help me put out good
content i also know that there's 39
people here who never heard of me who
right now are like looking into me and
16 of them are going to stick with me on
my journey i also know that there's nine
people here who have seen me in their
feed they're like [ __ ] that guy he's too
much whatever and they're like wait a
minute there might be something a little
bit deeper there he's not a full of [ __ ]
just all sizzle guy so you know it's
just you know what do you play for and i
play for different things and that's why
i think i get different results i
absolutely love it it's fascinating and
there will be plenty of people that hear
this and see this podcast when we put it
out that are gonna have a lot to say and
i'll share the feedback with you i can't
wait i gotta challenge you though so
you're motivated by the game which i
[ __ ] love i love the six million
dollar example that is so beautiful but
i also know one of your biggest things
in life that you say all the time is i
want to buy the new york jets so i did a
little work i saw that the jets about
two weeks ago were valued at about four
billion bucks my past life i was a
corporate banker i know let's say you
got to put at least a billion dollars
down to get that finance the nfl is even
worse because it works worse
let's say it's 50 right so 2 billion at
some point you got to be like how do i
get there and my question is to you
how is it that garyvee when you look
back and you do get there because every
place you want to travel you get do you
think you'll look back and say
this was the investment this was the
company or this is to come that'll put
you in that spot what will it be
it will be the fact that 13 years ago at
the height of my hype
in silicon valley
i could have raised 200 million dollars
for a fund
a vc firm
and deployed it and would have made as
you know back with your your background
two percent management fees on that
number
i would have hired some young kids that
knew the game which means i could have
taken a nice little salary of a million
bucks a year or so just to take meetings
and get 20 of the action i was hot
facebook twitter tumblr i was hot i was
three for three on the three biggest
things going
right
and i could have done that instead
i chose to be incredibly patient and
self-aware and say i'm the best marketer
in the world i think so
okay but i'm a human
but what if i built the best marketing
company in the world wouldn't that scale
all my activities wouldn't that mean
something and if i owned this asset i
could deploy it against all my things
that's what i've been doing rezzy the
restaurant app that you might be
familiar with a lot of people don't
realize i'm the co-founder of that and
that was breeded in vayner
empathy wines and we sold that to amex
in a nine figure deal empathy wines we
sold to consolation last year in an
eight potentially nine figure deal
depending on the earn out that was
incubated by two interns that worked for
me john troutman and nate schroeder
started as interns for me became my
minority partners and we sold that
incubate it right
garyvee the brand
literally me incubated by the machine
inside of it
my company vaynerx now in itself if i
liquidate here in the next year or two
puts me in striking distance to buy a
minority piece of the jets if the
johnsons would ever want that
and give me the first right to buy on
the way up already just that yet i view
that as secondary
v friends has generated me 51 million in
upfront sales and in 60 days
i think somewhere in the ballpark of
three or four million in residual
royalty sales because when you sell an
nft in the secondary market from
peer-to-peer the original ip owner takes
a rake and i have a 10 royalty on every
transaction
of a v friend in the last 24 hours i'm
gonna give you the exact data because
i'm on crypto slam right now i'll give
it to you hardcore right now
um crypto slam dot io v friends has done
four hundred and two thousand dollars in
secondary transactions i mean forty
thousand in
i don't think it's passive income
because people like the amount this was
my life's work to get to this moment
sure but the reality is it
between v friends and
vayner x i think i'm in dangerously
interesting striking distance as we
speak not to mention i bought a crypto
punks ape
that is extremely rare for 3.6 million
dollars the other day and i think it's
already worth 15 million and in 20 years
i think it's going to be worth 100
million because i think it's an andy
warhol and a jackson pollock and i
promise you when some crazy character
like me on the upper east side or upper
west side of manhattan or greenwich
connecticut in 1957 or 67 or 71 said i
just bought this warhol for 200 000 and
it's gonna be or this pollock for you
know 800 000 which is a lot of money
back then but it's gonna be worth 100
million everybody listening to that
person laughed them out of the room just
like everybody who just heard me say i
bought a jpeg for 3.7 million that i
think i'll sell for 100 million but i
know i'm right it's [ __ ] insane all
right two very basic questions i'm gonna
let you go because they're simple
answers but someone hears what you're
saying and now you have them intrigued
and they want to start just like someone
wants to start at a garage sale i want
to do something with an nft gary how
could someone like that go by an nft or
what would you suggest
30 hours of homework
okay before you do a single thing
you google what is an nft you go to
youtube what is an nft
and you literally watch or listen or
read for 30 hours and oh by the way
there's not a single person
who's listening to this that shouldn't
do it because nfts are going to eat up
life the way social media did and
whether as an investor as a career
change as something that's going to help
your family business
as a little side hustle or just
happiness little day trading of nfts to
make an extra 1800 bucks so your family
can go to a disney trip is fun but you
will lose your ass if you don't do 30
hours of homework 30 hours of homework
that's the answer second basic question
i need an answer to this okay so my
fiance was the bachelorette six years
ago being in the social media scene
she's now the co-host of the
bachelorette yes she gets
we all do we all get a lot of these
comments in these dms and you're saying
read them my question to you is a lot of
stuff with the good comes the bad there
comes a lot of hate a lot of chirping a
lot of things that you can't even
control like you're looking you're aging
all this [ __ ] how do you differentiate
what is a constructive piece of feedback
versus what is a negative piece of
feedback and then also how do you ignore
it because sometimes it hits in places
that hurts
great question and we're wrapping up
with this that's what i would love to
see
if somebody took the time
to dm you or
your partner in crime to say you don't
look as good as you used to
you were always full of [ __ ]
whatever this thing that they're trying
to tear you down
i genuinely deploy empathy when people
say i get lucky you're full of [ __ ] i
know that you're a con artist it's got
the other shoe's going to drip you've
been lucky you're not as good as you
think you are
i genuinely deploy empathy
for somebody the thought of spending my
time
to try to hurt somebody else's feelings
only goes to one place i have so much
compassion and sympathy to the hurt
like that is your life your life is that
you want to spend time making somebody
else feel bad is a 100 proxy to you're
not in a good place
and that and i deployed uh gratitude i
was lucky enough that i was an immigrant
that so i'm not entitled i didn't have
anything i had the greatest bomb in the
world that instilled so much self-esteem
in me that i never valued other people's
opinions which you can imagine even i
mean as early as high school no peer
pressure didn't do dumb [ __ ] didn't hurt
people like gave up popularity upside to
like be nice to people people were
picking on because you have to be mean
in high school to win in the 80s and 90s
like you know like did all these things
and like so i i would tell everybody
who's lucky enough that they have a
volume of hate coming at them
you know it's not as much as like [ __ ]
the haters or if they hate you they love
like it's like i hate when people put
down the person that's deploying the
hate yeah haters are going to hate or
trolls i don't feel that way about them
i feel like
they are
people that are hurting and i want to
like i like actually reply a lot of
times be like yo i'm sorry you think
that about me comma i really wish you
like happiness and health comma
can i do anything for you
yeah so much love compassion compassion
and energy all right when it's hurting
you it means you're insecure it means
you were playing for validation on the
outside to begin with
if you're hurt by somebody saying you're
not good looking anymore well then your
validation was coming from being good
looking this is why it's so important as
a parent to be balanced of what you're
saying to your kids you know if you're
telling your kid you're beautiful you're
beautiful you're beautiful she or he
and the world's gonna tell you it even
if your parents don't
so parents have to really guide that
balance like if you have a very
attractive child you can't triple
reinforce what they're feeling on the
outside you got to find the other [ __ ]
my mom made me feel great about how nice
i was that's why i think like my
content's crazy i'm an alpha out here
aggressive dude right and i'm out here
like empathy kindness compact like some
of my cool friends are like oh this is
some dork [ __ ] like in the beginning
you're like you're dork i'm like [ __ ]
you i'm like i believe that kindness is
good like i believe that like being
patient is fresh like like i believe
that [ __ ]
unbelievable so many garyvee so many uh
unbelievable financial and professional
tips but i gotta say i think probably
the most powerful tip of them all was
the last one you ended with i can't put
into words how much we appreciate your
time thank you so much thank you so much
cheers all right gary take care thanks
gary
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you